e aí olha que assistir ao canal todo
vocês comigo está tudo bem porque eu
estou um pouco nervoso que vai ter um e
nem aí né e até tensão começa a estudar
já eu tô aqui pra você e dicas de como
se dar bem no enem mais olinda só você
falou que você não gosta de estudar que
isso que aquilo então eu vou dizer que é
uma coisa que poucas pessoas sabem mas
eu já passei e nem assim ele é meu
terceiro ano no piso e neymar seja eu
passei pra as visuais não ia ser ótimo
mas eu não me matriculei porque não me
matriculei achei que não era hora de
fazer estudo ainda a recusar se a dois
anos e meio três anos largar e aí a
galera queria entrar no meu lugar não ia
poder mais entrar porque eu vou ganhar a
vaga dela e sair apoio não vão ficar de
boa vamos trabalhar um pouco e depois de
pablo leva à tela é muito novinha
assistir e alguns nem vão praticamente
não está no tempo ainda se você vai
fazer o enem vai fazer vestibular ainda
guardo essas dicas para no outro ano no
ano que vem passando o ano que vem você
faz vagas é a primeira dica é escolher
bem o seu curso é você que vai fazer nem
vai fazer vestibular e vai fazer direito
medicina porque o pai quer que você faça
um em um momento eu ainda sou nunes eu
aconselho você a sentar e conversar com
seu pai e sua mãe sobre aquilo que você
realmente quer porque você pode texto
você pode estudar se pode forçar pode
fazer tudo isso pode até passar direito
ao passarem ensina o papel do curso que
você queira que o seu pai que você passe
mas enquanto passava o tempo
infelizmente infelizmente a vida
acontece seu pai morrer só não vai
morrer se eu vou morrer e quem sabe
usando depois você pode perceber que não
é aquele que você queria ter feito
porque a gente é um quase certeza de que
deve ser uma merda cara você disse rico
você tem um trabalho que todo mundo quer
ter mas você deitar a cabeça no
travesseiro e falar porque eu tô falando
que eu não gosto disso eu queria ser
cantor
eu queria ser um artista plástico eu
prefiro ser sei lá um ator pobre lá cada
mais feliz do que ser um cara bem
sucedido milionário e triste eu prefiro
mil vezes ganhar pouco dinheiro deitar
na minha forma de nos falar porque [ __ ]
se eu faço todo mundo gosta de tal do
que você milionária está na minha também
não consegui dormir direito e se você
estiver pensando assim não mais ao longo
do tempo fazer medicina porque alguém
tem que ser em média cada tem gente
apaixonada por medicina tem gente que é
apaixonado por direito então deixe tem
apaixonar comercia fazer medicina eo bes
que é apaixonado por direito fazendo
direito deixa quem é apaixonado por
engenharia fazer dinheiro e faça o que
você sabe que você vai ser feliz no
futuro e que vai ser rentável também é
também não adianta querer ser vendedor
de cabas do egito não vai virar um mas
cabe triste ou a fazer vídeo para
internet e escolher o que você vai fazer
agora vamos ao dia da prova onde é muito
bom tudo pra vocês é escutar música
evangélica do trajeto de casa até o
lugar de fazer pronto não acerto tem
gente que só uma força divina mesmo a
passar quando pega o bilhete da bota no
bolsa tem sabor de mel tem samba de
mérida de que muricy já bota a mão nas
costas cantando acredite é hora de ir e
[Música]
vir de dentro de si
o passado é passado mas que é bem-vindo
limites acertando a regra
não é poder passar a engenharia elétrica
ii
então a dica fique calmo antes de fazer
a prova passada que fique calmo é muito
fácil ela fique carro ficar calma e de
forma a ficar totalmente é só se
distraía assistir um vídeo doentes no
youtube ainda estão mal suplicando
gostei não fiz tudo isso é uma coisa que
vai ajudar muito e ficar tal é não
conversar sobre o enem só porque você
não gosta de uma coisa nojenta ea outra
pessoa só vale coisa nojenta é você só
consegue pensar em coisa nojenta é
basicamente isso não fica falando sobre
o enem para você não ficar pensando só
em mim aí você vai se sair mais e aí vai
ficar mais legal é fazer a prova e não
pretendia que só liga para low profile
ano um bom dia mulher num o enem agora
editar a mulher e nem em outra equipe
que andou pra vocês é não estudar demais
mas o isso a minha lista seis horas por
dia tinha de dormir e 500 na redação foi
barrado pelo enem
o jovem só amiga feliz família passou
com certeza sua meio de uma coisa que
você não tem inteligência e também
prestou atenção nas aulas que assisti lá
a 5ª série na sexta oitava sério segundo
coisa que você não deve ter feito então
a pessoa que é inteligente prestar
atenção nas aulas do tipo já está
estudando foi nem agora ela está
aprendendo ela está relembrando o que
ela estudou agora você que não estudou
você não prestou atenção ou sequer bull
que nem eu você contar estudando foi nem
agora muito você não tá então você está
perdendo a cabeça precisa de tempo para
absorver o conhecimento ligado a outro
carro do satanás pela cabeça não vai
absorver isso tudo só vai muito além de
sobrecarregar a tua cabeça cheguei na
hora da prova não sabe de nada então
estudo de boa não é relembrada um bom
meia você dá um pouco mais de redação
operação conta muito e faz com que o
estudo o ano todo vai ter que estudar um
bancário de coisa que tu pensas vai cair
a questão é assim ea alternativa a
alternativa b que alternativas e ram
alternativa de dança kuduro alternativa
é tempo não tem nada a ver com que tudo
isto do andaluz que estava feito estudo
então estou de boa saúde boa a outra
dica que eu dou pra vocês é a fonofobia
outra dica que eu dou pra vocês é não
pesquisa tem como passar no enem o
google e não tem idéia da quantidade de
merda que você baixa ou vez só daqui
dica número 16 estude com um colega
gente gente não precisa nem muito
exposto você saber que estudar com o
colega nunca dá certo você vai ajudar um
colega o primeiro minuto é assim mas foi
a primeira questão que a língua
pertençam
o ato andar do minuto assim não dá certo
o estudo com outra pessoa não sei que o
professor não estudo pode número 7
leonor a fio d'água com uma barra de
cereal chocolates não é comida marmita
não combina bem com o enem o que para o
que leva marmita cá ainda vencer avisou
o 'he-man' quais eu levo um fogão quatro
bocas para fazer feijoada ou ao tipo de
personalidade que se acha na internet
pois é né
então se você vai fazer o enem fique de
boa para falar do teu tempo para a
dirigente que você quer ali que eu dou é
só treinar uma redação que tem muita
gente muito atualizado hoje ela conhece
muitos bebês e escrever uma coisa que se
espera na internet que o enem não é
permitido não tenho porque a redação
fala muito e se você não passar no enem
não vai morrer por causa de todo ano tem
nem se pode fazer noturna quando você se
prepara melhor não posso perder um ano
da minha vida porquanto pode morrer a
qualquer momento de resgatar essa roupa
um carro que mata a partir da cidade por
uma bala perdida tumor está se
preocupando com um ano não passou
vai com cursinho vai fazer alguma coisa
estuda mais um pouco no próximo passo é
assim que se faz uma distinção teve a
ajuda de alguma coisa tá que gostei dele
e comenta o que você quer fazer da sua
vida em que você quer passar no enem não
está escrito esse canal que ele escreveu
a vontade de ver de novo a inibição de
humor apesar de este ano ter sido tanto
de um outro que mais dá uma ajuda aí pra
galera mas é isso aí muito obrigado a
desistir de vir até aqui e falei que é e
francia da minha ajuda nesse nem limitar
o euro passar